an icy wind
blows over the permafrost on the
desolate
cola peninsula this
is an unforgiving landscape barren and
isolated
but it is where the soviet union hoped
to make history
inside a small concrete overstructure
with corrugated iron panels rattling in
the wind
a huge drill bit more than 20
centimeters in diameter
is lowered towards the ground and begins
to descend
[Music]
the year is 1970
and the cold war race for technological
supremacy between the u.s and soviet
superpowers
is according to some over the americans
beat the reds to the moon the previous
summer
and space is now adorned with stars and
stripes the russian cosmonauts are
forever
runners-up but there is another
lesser-known cold war contest that the
soviets
can still win one not focused up
towards the stars but down into
the earth to drill to the bottom of the
earth's crust
reach the mantle the russians prospects
are good
since the u.s abandoned their attempt
four years earlier
just as with the race to the moon the
motivation for digging to the bottom of
the crust was ostensibly a scientific
one
although we have rocks that have been
uplifted altered and fractured from the
top of the mantle
we don't have any fresh samples from
this huge shell of scorching
flowing rock geologists don't know for
sure its composition
temperature or dynamics for that reason
the americans began an ambitious project
in 1958
to drill deeper than ever before to
reach
the maharavich discontinuity known
as the moho which is the boundary
between the mantle
and the crust for this so-called project
mohol
they chose to drill into the sea floor
where the oceanic crust is thinner
unfortunately that meant drilling from a
floating platform on the open ocean
something that is common now but had
never been done before
the development costs soared and the
project was abandoned in 1966
they had drilled just 183 metres down
so in 1970 the soviets began their own
effort
to reach the moho they only needed to
drill deeper than 183 meters to
decisively beat the americans
at this earth race on the stable
arctic ground of the kola peninsula it
was a simple prospect
here the crust is much thicker up to 30
kilometers of rock lies between the
surface and the moho
but there were none of the difficulties
of drilling at sea
the russians could take it slow and
steady inching down through rock layers
until their goal was in sight
the kohler super deep borehole is only
20 centimeters wide
but it passes through 12 kilometers
the deepest man-made hole on the planet
and these super deep rocks give
scientists an incredible
timeline view of the early earth
and at around 2 billion years old these
rocks have been
folded faulted and squeezed
metamorphosed into new forms
but they can still be reconstructed to
give a glimpse of the environments of
their formation
there are the remnants of volcanoes
river and ocean sediments
even organic microfossils
it reveals a surprisingly normal picture
of earth
almost recognizable
and yet elsewhere rocks from just a
hundred million years earlier
tell a very different story of chemical
and climatic catastrophe that brought
the entire
living planet to its knees
this begs the question how
did the earth transform from this barren
rock to the beginnings of the world we
know today
and was the earth two billion years ago
really as idyllic as the rocks
seem to show
[Music]
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
big thanks to everyone who subscribed to
the new channel and if you haven't
check it out mind melting stuff and as
with history of the earth it pairs very
well
with magellan tv magellan has a huge
range of documentaries on a huge range
of topics
from dinosaurs to the edge of
theoretical physics
one example we enjoyed recently was
earth in 1 000
years a fascinating insight into what
the future holds for our planet a great
companion piece for this video
and one of more than 3 000 documentaries
available
and you can now take advantage of an
exclusive offer
30 off an annual membership this gives
you an entire year for less than 3.50
a month even if you've joined magellan
before elapsed
you can simply click on the link in the
description to claim your discounted
membership today
[Music]
thanks
viewed from afar the early proterozoic
earth
looked dead at 2 billion years old
the earth is only just past half its
current age
barely further from the moment of its
formation as it is
from today it has been through extremes
of temperature
from the molten heat of its formation to
the gripping cold of a global ice age
on this watery ball of rock the most
unlikely thing happened
life evolved that life learned to thrive
in all the environments earth had to
offer
invented new ways of getting energy and
almost killed itself in the process
through chemical then climatic
catastrophe
the global huronian glaciation had been
triggered by the photosynthetic release
of oxygen into the atmosphere
stripping the air of its most potent
greenhouse gas
methane while the photosynthetic
bacteria continued to gobble carbon
dioxide
thinning the planet's insulating blanket
even further
now exposed to the weak rays of a still
young
sun the planet was chilled to its
equator
oceans once resplendent in blue and
green were covered by quiet
still sea ice ice covered the land too
as the last of the clouds deposited
their icy loads over high peaks
what was next for the surface of the
planet trapped inside this
seemingly eternal icy prison
[Music]
two years after soviet drilling began in
the arctic
french engineers discovered a two
billion year old mystery in rocks
close to the equator solving that
mystery
would help to shed light on a
proterozoic world
emerging from cryostasis
the pierlat nuclear processing plant on
the banks of the rhone in southeastern
france
was a facility dedicated to enriching
uranium from its mine doors
for use in power plants and nuclear
weapons thanks to the escalations of the
cold war
scientists understood the properties of
uranium and its ores pretty well by 1972
they knew for example that every natural
source of uranium on
earth in meteorites and on the moon had
three uranium isotopes versions of the
same element with slightly different
masses
and these were always in the same ratio
the most radioactive uranium-235
always made up 0.72 percent
of the total
so the french engineers were puzzled to
discover that a batch of uranium from
their mines in gabon
contained less than this only 0.6
percent
the difference may be small but it was
unheard of anywhere else on
or off the planet from one source
up to 200 kilograms of uranium seemed to
be missing
enough to make a dozen nuclear warheads
geologists were sent to the oclo mine in
gabon
to investigate this worrying discrepancy
but they found no misconduct no uranium
theft
instead they uncovered a remarkable
natural phenomenon
a natural nuclear reactor
deep in the proterozoic rocks that had
been
smoldering away for hundreds of
thousands of years
the heavy element uranium is formed
under special conditions when stars
explode
in devastating supernova when the earth
first
formed around the newly ignited sun it
captured free-floating uranium from the
swirling disk of dust and gas that
writhed around the young star
and so our planet is filled with it
inside and out
but uranium is of greatest interest to
us humans
when it is concentrated further allowing
us to easily extract its oars for use
in our energy-hungry warring
civilizations
one of the best ways for uranium to be
gathered together and concentrated
is through the vast cycling of rocks and
water through the surface layers of the
earth
the element can dissolve in water and be
transported along with river sediments
or
through hydrothermal plumbing systems
that surround
volcanoes at the oclo mine in gabon the
uranium had been gathered together by
mineralizing volcanic fluids that flowed
through
truly ancient sedimentary rocks rich in
organic carbon
and around two billion years ago
tectonic forces began to uplift these
rocks
towards the surface along with their
uranium mineral
veins it appeared that the particular
natural
processes operating here were enough to
concentrate
the uranium-235 to far higher levels
than is normally found as they were
uplifted towards the surface
groundwater would penetrate the rocks
and surround the uranium
the water acts to slow down the neutron
products of radioactive decay
keeping them close and helping to
trigger a chain reaction
within the densely concentrated uranium
deposit
and so a self-sustaining nuclear
reaction
could continue naturally for a while
eventually the heat released by the
ongoing decay would be enough to boil
the mediating water
creating powerful plumes of radioactive
steam
that burst out of the earth's surface
like toxic
geezers when these yellow-ringed geezers
erupt
the reaction underground slows to a halt
without the water to sustain the fission
the decay products fly harmlessly away
and so this continued in pulses of
fission that lasted 30 minutes
this faithful cycle continued for
hundreds of millennia
until the uranium at oclo once so rich
was depleted
below natural levels and the natural
reactor
fell silent forever
the discovery of a two billion-year-old
nuclear reactor in the rocks of gabon
was groundbreaking confirming theories
made decades earlier
but as well as giving us a window into a
bizarre and dynamic environment
that existed 2000 million years ago they
also tell us a lot
about normal earth processes at this
time
[Music]
there were stable sedimentary
environments
like rivers deltas and shallow ocean
basins
where living things lived and died in
great numbers to enrich the sediments in
organic carbon
these sediments and their resulting
rocks are suffused with hydrothermal
and volcanic plumbing systems which
concentrate rare minerals and alter the
chemistry of the very rocks they
penetrate
and tectonic forces continually warp
these rocks as they are formed
forcing them deeper down into the crust
or uplifting them to the surface
where they are exposed to water air and
biological attack
that all may sound familiar indeed they
are the very processes that shape the
surface of our planet today
but they are a surprise coming so soon
after the vicious
huronian big freeze although
gabon doesn't tell us how it shows us
that
two billion years ago the earth
does emerge it has been covered by ice
from pole to equator
for hundreds of millions of years
life has struggled on where it could
but now thanks to forces hidden deep
within the earth
the tide is quite literally
beginning to turn
[Music]
in the grip of the huronian glaciation
there are only a few places where any
activity
could be seen for beneath the silent
surface of the ice
the interior of the planet is still
incredibly hot
volcanoes pierce through the shell
flashing orange lava that cools to black
rock
and spews gray ash over the pristine
white surface
water bodies close to these volcanic
pustules are warm enough to stave off
the encroaching ice
and become refugia for the one percent
of life that clung on
desperately through the endless winter
the volcanoes that punch through the
surface are the outward expression of
huge and slow tectonic forces
gradually transforming the crust great
rafts of rock
bumped together and grind powered by
horizontal convection within the roiling
mantle
where one slips beneath another gravity
tugs at the suspended slab
pulling the rest of the raft sideways
behind it
these so-called subducting margins are
the key
to plate tectonics and throughout the
huronian glaciation
hidden beneath the ice plate tectonics
is reconfiguring
the first continental masses
over hundreds of millions of years
although scientists aren't certain when
exactly true plate tectonics was
established the rocks that remain from
this time from gabon
and from the kola peninsula among others
bear the telltale signs of this
continental dance the earliest volcanoes
on the earth would have been black
shallow shields like those on hawaii and
iceland today
formed by lava that flowed freely
following the slightest gradient and
flooding far from the source before they
froze solid
where plates collide they engage in a
tectonic sumo
that crumples and thickens the crust
lifting up mountain ranges and forcing
down
routes that plunge tens of kilometers
further into the mantle
at subducting margins water released
from the doomed slab
melts the mantle around it creating
magma that flows upwards
and into the mountain's roots this magma
cannot escape so
easily and it sits buried at the heart
of the mountain for hundreds of
thousands of years
its dark-coloured heavy minerals
crystallize and sink to the bottom
leaving behind a new kind of magma that
is paler
stickier and infused with gas
when this magma eventually reaches the
surface it creates
a very different kind of volcano when
the lava flows
it doesn't make it far before cooling
and stopping building up huge
conical piles and the pressure from
magmar and gas
continue to build until devastating
explosions blow the volcanic pile apart
these eruptions sound out around half
the globe
and loft ash and noxious vapors high
into the sky
to be carried great distances by fast
jet streams
in this way these stratovolcanoes build
up
tall cones and blow themselves apart
time and time again
[Music]
while we know these thickened volcanic
ranges existed
the fragmented geological remains from
this time
make it difficult to know exactly how
the early continents
were arranged geologists looked closely
at the volcanic and metamorphic rocks
from two billion years ago
to reconstruct the collisions that must
have formed them
and the continental fragments involved
in those conjunctions
and there is growing evidence that
almost all of the continental land
masses
were compressed together to form one
huge supercontinent known
as colombia
researchers believe colombia spanned
some 13
000 kilometers north to south larger
than modern-day eurasia
from portugal to the burring strait
for much of the early proterozoic though
this impressive supercontinent
was still covered in ice the bright
white of glaciers
ice caps and ice shelves only serves to
reflect the sun's heat back into space
prolonging the chill for millions of
years more than any normal ice age
it seems hard to believe that the planet
will ever be able to break
free but the hot interior is to be
earth's
savior with each continental collision
with each new explosive volcano
water vapor and carbon dioxide is being
pumped back
into the atmosphere gradually the
atmosphere regains its ability to trap
the sun's heat
and with every year that passes that
sun's heat
grows slightly as our home star matures
it becomes more luminous increasing its
brightness by six percent
every billion years after 300 million
years on ice
a hotter sun and better insulation means
the earth is
finally able to emerge from its big
freeze
just as the white ice had reflected the
sun's warmth
the newly exposed dark oceans and land
surfaces absorb it
speeding up the ice's retreat it may
have only taken
a few hundred years for earth to be
reborn
but all of the water once locked away in
ice
must go somewhere
[Music]
and that somewhere is of course the
oceans huge influxes of fresh water into
the proterozoic oceans creates a global
sea level rise of massive proportions
coastlines are drowned
and the colombian supercontinent shrinks
from its edges
as newly formed land surfaces are
reclaimed
by the sea and worldwide
rocks from two billion years ago
preserve the record
of this global flood known to geologists
as a marine transgression sedimentary
rocks
gradually encroach over older weathered
land surfaces
and we can reconstruct wide continental
shelves
bearing vast river deltas
where water breaches hilly landscapes
sheltered bays and lagoons are formed
scalloping the edges of the continent
these shallow waters are filled with
fine
rich sediments the product of new
erosional chemistry on virgin rock
surfaces
the lagoons turn a tropical blue
as gentle waves lap the fractal
coastline
the planet basks in the sun
the great flood that took place two
billion years ago
was indeed a monumental event but it was
not
an apocalyptic one for a living
biosphere confined to the oceans
the drowning of the shoreline was to be
celebrated
not feared the marine transgressions
served to create a veritable eden
for the photosynthetic life-forms that
craved both the water
and the light and in this newfound
paradise
they wasted no time in expanding
multiplying and even experimenting
[Music]
since the 19th century discovery of
iron-rich rocks along the southern
shores of lake superior in north america
a thriving iron and steel industry has
developed
across the region these rocks alone may
be thanked for the success of the
automobile industry in detroit
which came to transform the face of
america itself
so it is little surprise that these
proterozoic deposits
have been the subject of much study over
the last 150 years
by understanding exactly how they formed
when
and under what conditions geologists
hope to unlock the proterozoic rock
record
and reveal more ancient hidden treasures
and this is exactly what stanley tyler
professor of geology at the university
of wisconsin
happened upon in the early 1950s
tyler and his team had dug a test pit 20
feet deep
into the iron-bearing rocks of iron
river michigan
and retrieved samples from the deepest
layers
the sample tyler held in his hand was
deep
black and glinted in the sun
it was something he'd seen before but
never expected in rocks so ancient
it looked to his educated eye just
like coal
[Music]
before their investigations could
continue however disaster struck
and the walls of the pit collapsed
burying this mysterious sample source
beneath tons of jumbled rock so tyler
turned to another expert in the field
a paleobotanist at harvard named elso
barkhorn
for a second opinion on this precious
rare sample of proterozoic coal
both men knew that the earliest
confirmed instances of coal on earth
were much
much younger these rocks were nearly 2
billion years old
whereas most coal is a mere 350 million
years old
dating to the age of trees in the
carboniferous period
but when barkhorn examined tyler's
samples
he confirmed the geologist's suspicions
this sample was nearly 80 percent pure
organic carbon and he concluded
must have been biological in origin
fine scale structures within this
ancient coal told of algae
not trees being the source of such
prolific productivity
colonies of photosynthesizing bacteria
grew in such numbers in the shallow
proterozoic seas
that they left behind layers of coal to
rival
the great age of trees one and a half
billion years later
a few years later tyler and berghorn
ventured out together
following the shore of lake superior
north into canada
in search of more evidence of this
ancient algal forest
traveling by boat they hopped between
shoreline outcrops where the gentle
waves of the lake
kept a marching spruce and pine forests
at bay
here in the gunflint range of ontario
they discovered dome-shaped layered
structures
that had been cross-cut by the waves
leaving concentric
rings in the smooth rock that dipped to
the water's edge
these were stromatolites
towering microcosms built layer by layer
by sun-loving photosynthetic bacteria
elsewhere the pair discovered layers of
chert
a glassy silicate rock also known as
flint
which gives the gunflint range its name
this church was as black as the cold
tyler had found years before
so the professors gathered as much as
they could for closer study
when they got back on dry land
they carefully sliced and ground
paper-thin sections of the dark chert
until light could pass easily through
the silicate minerals
under the microscope the course of the
black color
was finally revealed these cherts
contained an astonishing number and
array
of microfossils these tiny
carbon structures were just a few ten
thousandths of a millimeter across
but they were complex and definitely
biological
[Music]
with this in 1953 stanley tyler
and elsa barkhorn became the first to
discover fossils
that predated the age of animals
the gunflint microbiota were the oldest
fossils of the time
by some one and a half billion years
stanley tyler had set out to uncover
wonders in the iron formations of
michigan and ontario
and the microscopic world he revealed
was wondrous
beyond anything he could have imagined
[Music]
the abundance of diversity of microbial
fossils in the proterozoic gunflint
shirts
proved that life had wasted no time in
bouncing back from the great oxygen
extinction
by two billion years ago the shallow
seas were once again
teeming with life and the new
generations were resilient
to the once poisoned gas that now filled
the atmosphere
still proterozoic oxygen levels did not
come close to modern concentrations
but there was enough for new
transformations to begin
at the top of the atmosphere ultraviolet
radiation from the sun
splits molecules of oxygen apart and
recombines them
into ozone forming an invisible layer in
the stratosphere that absorbs
uv light before it reaches the surface
without this damaging radiation washing
over the land and ocean surfaces
photosynthetic life could now survive
closer to the ocean's surface than ever
before
even moving to colonize the wide tidal
flats created by the global sea level
rise
with protective ozone the new shallow
lagoons that ring the colombian
supercontinent
are an algal playground and their
turquoise
soon turns green with verdant blooms
in this newfound eden life finally has
the freedom to do more
than just survive it thrives feeding off
the bounty from the earth and the sun
developing new ways of gaining the upper
hand from their bacterial brothers
new cooperative relationships between
different types of bacteria
are now more boldly pursued incomplete
predation sees prey enslaved within the
bodies of their masters
and the two together forge a new branch
on the tree of life
as the first eukaryotes there is no
direct fossil evidence of eukaryotic
cells from 2 billion years ago
and scientists aren't sure exactly when
this critical transition took place
but a few curious fossils from gabon
may suggest that elsewhere more complex
cells allowed for experimentation
into entirely new ways of life
[Music]
one such fossil could be easily
dismissed as simple gouges in the
surface of a smooth grey mudstone
but closer examination of these gouges
show that they are connected
beneath the surface creating tubular
tunnels and tracks like some tortured
ancient subway system
although no evidence remains of the
organisms that created them
organic carbon left behind seems to
confirm their biological origin
at 2.1 billion years old they
are the earliest footprints in the sand
our first evidence of creatures moving
by themselves scientists imagine they
were created by a slug-like colony of
amoeba-like cells moving together
tunneling through soft sediment and
bacterial mats
in search of nutrients or protection
another fossil from gabon has received a
more critical review
not least because it suggests an even
more radical biological experiment
at 12 centimeters across this curious
flattened form
resembles a fried egg with scalloped
edges
its discoverers claim that they are the
fossilized remains of multicellular
organisms
fourteen hundred million years before
multicellularity
really took off others are more
skeptical suggesting the structures
could be formed by
purely physical processes and just
happen to resemble
lifelike structures if they do represent
an experiment in life growing large
then that experiment was a failed one
these proterozoic
fried eggs are not seen anywhere else in
the world
or in any younger layers of rock
yet it is clear that the earth now
belongs
to its life forms there is no longer any
force
chemical or physical holding them back
the shallow
supercontinental shelf turns green
as life traps carbon and stains the sea
floor
black with its dead
and so on the kola peninsula in the
russian arctic
the soviet super deep borehole
penetrates the proterozoic rocks
revealing sequences of organic rich
sediment
light-colored volcanic rock and frozen
magma
from the heart of ancient
supercontinental mountains
the russians succeeded where the
americans failed
and drilled on for 20 years they spun up
their drills and
inched further and further into the
crust but they never reached
the moho never touched the mantle
the borehole bottomed out to 12 and a
quarter kilometers deep
it is sealed by an iron cap and remains
the deepest mankind has ever dug
we still haven't reached the mantle and
we know much more about the surface of
the moon
than we do about the inside of our
planet but the cola borehole
still achieved something unexpected from
the icy wastes of the arctic
it allowed us to peer back in time
and discover paradise
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to check out
our partner channels
history of the universe and something
incredible
and we'll see you next time